what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to start up Star Wars Visions
we're gonna do this three episodes per video
Michael you good we gotta get to it buddy we got
a lot of Visions to watch be good I'm good so good
good they gotta leave a like use the force leave a
like that would mean a lot also by the way full
interaction watching alongs where you sing with
your own copy of Visions available for super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page thank you to all who
have joined us over there so far so many of you
have joined all of our Star Wars Visions reactions
we got a sponsor who I love working with get
out of the video for a little bit Michael thank
you again to meonies for sponsoring this video
guys I'm in a onesie I've never owned a onesie
and my epidermis has never felt more comfortable
nay I need a better word than comfortable I feel
has snug as a bug in a rug I obviously love their
clothing I went to the Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 premiere and I even wore the Rocket Raccoon
lounge pants and people would not stop talking
about it easily the most comfortable one there
at the event now I'm venturing further into the
galaxy far far away you might say with this
limited edition print of grogu AKA baby Yoda
cause the child himself grogu has traveled
across the Galaxy and into our hearts and
now you can meditate with him and galactically
soft undies socks bralettes loungewear and more
available in sizes extra small to 4XL like I
said the new Star Wars Prince is limited so
grab this bounty now before it's all gone they
also gave me their shorts which again is so soft
and perfect fitting too even my wife loves
to wear them speaking of my wife I even got
this bralette for her too I said take it off
I'm showing it in the video a woman she loves
seeing me in this underwear my Jedi Mind Tricks
to keep her attracted to me don't work but this
underwear is doing the job wearing it right now
I've never been more relaxed on camera sitting
has just generally never felt so soothing
but yes rejection the hype is real you're
not impressed with me undies your first pair is
on the house Seth is a promise so to get 25 off
your first order and free standard shipping go to
mianis.com rejects once again that is miyanis.com
Rejects and May the force be with you always I
hope they partner up with us again because yes
[Music]
I'd like to hear it oh very
interesting oh we're after a good start
this is gorgeous
Gorge awesome I did not know
a Droid POV is what I needed
this looks like the show arcane
Wally
I love the look of this I
would watch a show of this
will inspire me to finish the painting
let's see through paints [Music]
wow this feels so cyber punky
love it Star Wars into the star version
just a really neat concept to
explore a force using artists
wow look at that oh the dimension
shift it's like an iMac shift wow
it's just like the use of transparency there's
a video game where you just like paint like this
that's pretty cool what that game's
called but it looks like this
oh interesting there's the Sith
I love their use of just like loose sketches
I expect the first episode to have such
mind-blowing animation yeah oh hello there
oh it's like the Sith is
dripping I hate when that happens
oh she like sensing the Sith
maybe this is how she expresses her
dark side Beacon seven always failing
this is about to be you absolutely gorgeous I
can feel it the rebels are left you're so cool
oh man it reminds me a bit of Grievous ship
great shot
I'm actually sure they have like that identical
shot in the Ahsoka trailer but of Sabine [Music]
oh the platformings look like an eye is
watching her this doesn't look stay here
I love this Droid someone destroyed this
I literally I right yeah yeah that's exactly
what they're going for oh I love this guy
those are some cool tendrils
paint over him uh-oh you
you I know safe anymore Ah
that's a nice change of pace
yeah I love this electronic score
oh baby
it's like a nebula Winter Soldier yeah
okay
holy [__] I just got goosebumps everywhere
this is so cool
oh man she just wants to paint Tred better be okay
oh boy oh don't you dare vision
that was great right the Dome
no oh didn't even the news Star Wars
the paint might actually be part
of this oh wow pain over him
floors some stuff they're so dramatic
[__]
Ray Skywalker that's like a cool Tonto
oh my God oh my God this is beautiful
wow
[Music]
found my own path
you're in her world now the Light Side
Darkness this is so freaking beautiful
let's talk about visual language
and darkness yes balance
oh [__] it's great brilliant I love this guys
I'm not even joking I'm literally editing this
right now and I I just had chills the entire
time just editing this episode that's so good
oh damn that's like some Thanos level
of beliefs right here gets killed is
like yes you did good daughter
you have a thick skin buddy no
I love this ship
gorgeous
nice great painting balance he was right about
one thing I am the master now and I can paint I
am the master now
paint your own destiny gorgeous I loved
it two out of ten Greg clearly not enough
lizzo we gotta keep these short because we got
ourselves a few more to get through my God I
was like a combination of the animation from
like Arcane Spider-Man into the spider-verse
whatever I saw in the trailer for puss and moves
I haven't actually seen Puss in Boots lately mixed
with a bit of that like ethereal tone of like
a Leica film you know those types of properties
like ParaNorman another one I haven't uh well no
I've seen paranormal ParaNorman and they're like
Coraline and stuff like that like those kind of
movies as well I love how this was about a person
who just painting as her New Path they kept that
as a consistent aesthetic throughout the entire
experience and its expression I thought it was
beautiful I would have watched an entire like 80
to 90 minute movie if this was the case I fell
in love with that instantly I completely agree
uh I I think striking that creative balance was
just so refreshing and I think it's my favorite
part of Visions is expressing the force through
these kind of visual means allows you to just
do so much more than you know what the traditional
films and and TV shows are able to do so yeah cool
we got a Latino actress in there to do it yeah
awesome that was badass yeah yeah I I completely
agree and it's it's one of those like de facto
representation is my favorite representation
where it's not even like it's just it's not
even a thing yeah I didn't even think about
it until you said that which is awesome I saw
the director was like Rodrigo or something or
another I don't know what else he's done but yeah
that was awesome what did you guys think about it
leave it down below I guess my one worry is
like did you start off so high that it can't
match that high yeah it was just the trick to get
us to watch another one was this the peak of Nine
episodes we'll see how it goes but I thought
that was mesmerizing absolutely mesmerizing
screen choose reach ah
space orphans am I right yeah pick you up
this is really cool I like the 2D effect I
feel like I'm uh playing The Fallout Shelter
mobile game it literally looks like a Pip
Boy it's like an arcade level of like the
old school games Donkey Kong up on the top
[Music]
I would play this game I'm going to screeches
reach no way that place is haunting we
steal some speeders uh what's going
on oh my God you want to see a ghost
did they say his name is Cal
M this is really really pretty
it's so nice to see 2D animation just just doing
its thing hand-drawned or something to it I mean
obviously a little bit digital touch-up but
at least the Android effect yeah the ghost
creatures reach well we're gonna be the first
oh face the sound of that screaming no they're
just stories right now tell the ghost isn't
a thing you can touch you see it in your
mind plus Cal's not Irish I'm the redheads
beats the workhouse what if you didn't have
to go back to the workhouse or a girl there
are worse lives now There Are Better Lives
where you could use the horse that got out of here
yeah
oh this is cute you've always wanted something
more on it what that is take it don't look back
you're gonna travel in style better hold on
that's all expressed we're going on an adventure
it's a little bit dark in here we'll stop we'll
stop I follow your path with strength and courage
a good little catholic
[Music]
loving this music doll we need to stick together
oh my gosh Dow I've heard a different
name every time he said their name
's in here haunting I don't want to see a ghost
I saw the ghosts
holy [__] wow
there's like some J horror crap I'm here for it
oh wow
she's in pain
what's your motive here
don't worry
why are you trying to defeat this thing
that was unexpected
it's like a soul has become so corrupt
oh [Music] wow that is terrifying
go towards the light
oh that was an amazing shot oh
creepy demonic and fast that thing was but
it still needed a lightsaber to get the job
struck me down in anger [Music] but I'll become
more powerful than you could possibly imagine
oh wow Sal's first kill I murdered a crazy
[__] nothing helps me find the
Light Side better than murder
and permanently scared you gave me
strength it's time for time to meet
Guided by a Sith that was a nice plot twist
oh that's cool
we'll strike down your friends now
damn the way that boat ship moves
down the foreground moves with it
hello there the true test is always
in your mind and you did what you
had to do right this looks like the
Yellow Submarine cartoon come child
are my friends too no
it's only you
don't look back right [Music]
oh so misguided
fascinating it's like a cautionary
tale of Temptation that is awful
this is dark and beautiful
that left me very hungry for more it happens man
take it away Michael I kicked off the first one
you kick off this one I loved that I was
not expecting that uh watching Star Wars
is really hard these days uh no I mean it
it was uh beautiful I also just like from a
Star Wars perspective there's something really fun
about like exploring someone getting recruited to
the dark side who is literally just trying to like
Escape their means I loved the animation style it
captured a child like in a sense that I think
made the story all the more like oh that's just
so unsettling uh and also the ghost was terrifying
uh I think straight up was like don't poop your
pants on the real rejects uh and I didn't want
to be the first time someone's done it I believe
that uh I believe that not naming any names yeah
what did you think Greg uh yeah I thought it was
great I mean it's it's yeah it's definitely like
an adjustment to go from the first one to this one
because they're such different Vibes and I kind
of like prepared ourselves for yeah all right you
know they usually start off strong let's see how
it goes but I thought this was great yeah I mean
the latter half of it was the most enticing
part when it actually became something that
felt horrific everything with the ghost that I
thought was cool it's like when the ghost said
the lightsaber was like we really need to go
with the lightsaber at this point I had that
thing tick off in my brain but for ultimately what
it turned into um because I like how they use they
have to tell these stories at a very they rely
so much on tone and mood and the atmosphere they
have to have this like very strong laconic way
of expressing themselves I think they did just
that so they didn't have the reveal come around
like you talked about the innocence and how this
Sith preys on innocence presents themselves as
it's like a savior into a new beautiful kind
of world like look at me doubt and white in the
light but you know it's a Sith I think is great
because this kid has no idea like you're actually
going on a really dark path right now yeah yeah
but they don't know so I think that's compared to
being stuck true that's true yeah that's uh no I I
completely agree as a Storyteller I have so much
respect for this kind of short form storytelling
because in an age where we rely so much upon like
lore and an exposition and all you know what's
become an essential part of the viewing experience
it is really really refreshing to in the familiar
broad setting of a story like Star Wars be able
to just give storytellers a like unconsequential
to Canon opportunity to explore a deeper more
meaningful art form and honestly like for all the
things that people say about Lucas film huge Kudos
because green lighting a project like this and
giving it two seasons is a pretty extraordinary
move you know especially when you consider every
one of these companies is like a legendary
Animation Studio in their own right and yeah
um for them to take their time teams and talent
and like find me a single Storyteller artist that
wasn't inspired by Star Wars like you can only
imagine in a creative process for each of these
there's this like overwhelming feeling of like
wow this might be my one chance to get to leave
my mark on this galaxy sure and like they don't
disappoint true true let's watch the third one and
get disappointed Greg yeah you know great points
but we got seven of these more to go through
so comfortable in this okay
Punk Robot in the Stars it all takes place and
it doesn't have this better be a musical oh I'm
really curious what the rest of the style is
gonna be up that playmation that's gorgeous wow
they are spoiling us
magic mushrooms
this kind of reminds me a little bit
of uh Andor and the star sequence they
had kind of wow there's a real
uncanny effect here this is cool
that Searchlight yeah I was gonna
say TIE fighter with a spotlight
oh
are you pretending to be a Jedi
I love how you can feel the scale
these sets are so pretty that's the rock where
aslen was resurrected you are wasting it no this
is important it's from Anna Stone I've really
been enjoying the voiceover work too yeah right
[Music]
oh wow do you still remember Sister oh
I feel like six mom had a great strength
she always said that we had it too Lilo and Stitch
we were happy then God this is beautiful they came
so cool it's like the historical cave
paintings yeah I love it calligraphy
this is exposition done right for the record oh
[Music]
Man became a star oh all right everybody
looking down on us from the sky
converted back to New energy be one
with the Stars we're not alone we are
what a cool wall have your history
just etched onto there drink my
Mission this would have been beautiful to see
on the big screen we don't have more clean water
that would have been nice for them to
do like the old days when they'd show
short animated films or yeah great use of these
[Music]
that's exactly what godmother
deals literally Lilo and Stitch
yeah this is so beautiful just
takes that long to get there huh
what are they producing here
it looks like a water treatment
facility which seems stupid because
they could have just not poisonous
God all this work to barely get any water
ah
same thing I mean whenever I babysit
I like these uniforms yeah
stop right there oh
now this is a Star Wars level
oh this music
[Music]
back down doing useful stuff
I'll rent you
should you still have the water yeah I hope so
I love these it's like the animation is
such a character in these oh I completely
agree the textures of their costumes
I thought there were none of them left
oh it's nice to see a woman Imperial
officer for once I want to know we won one
does that reach your quota yeah after that's broke
this little girl man you're gonna
get your older sister killed [Music]
you're going to get your older sister killed man
pick up the broomstick pick up the
broomstick what do you think you are doing
man this planet resources
belong to Queen Elizabeth sorry
it seems like a really uneffective or unnecessary
[Music]
I swear if she dies she has the force
her sister's gonna have the force
[Music]
come on there it is
again very unnecessary crush it
together come on together do what
your sister was trying to do foreign
that is touching wow this is
really moving Ohana means family
wow
this is gorgeous
these are in clean water
now the alkaline purifies it
all the medicalorians
skies are clear their mom starts gonna
be so proud of them they are all here
[Music]
and this season's on another
level Jesus Christ [Music]
are they all look at this consistent wow
oh my god oh it chills again man oh gosh
mom we will never be alone
boy that was beautiful oh man God I hate this
show that's great so I hate feelings just when
that little girl was starting to get on
my nerves oh she brought out the good in
her yeah I mean I like the I'd like to switcher
of the character because he had that the little
girl's owner believes and the energy and the force
and all that and then the older ones more of the
the hardened shell the one who's experienced
too much loss and pain and doesn't believe in
any of that stuff and then finds it in the most
desperate moment and I thought that was such a
beautiful reveal for her to have the character
Arc there um but yeah I thought that was great
obviously like it's it you'll probably just hear
saying this throughout every episode it's gorgeous
animation because it is it's gorgeous but I like
the variety of it especially with the claymation
where you part of the joy of claymations when
you can feel the scale of the models get a
sense of like the set like you can feel some
of the filmmaking behind it where it has this
like one-two effect of like observing admiration
and also feeling lived in simultaneously and not
too many animations house can do that and I feel
like that's what a proper stop-motion claymation
can do stop motion claymation I don't know what
the proper term is for it is another great like
tonal display of white people taking over native
cultures poisoning their lands you're not wrong
that's what they did freaking whites Oh I thought
they were pretty very pretty color palettes no uh
uh I thought they captured the duality of
grief especially in losing a parent really
really well where there's almost this feeling
of like I can remove the force the force being
the metaphor here like I can never be what my
parent or my you know role model or whomever
you know and uh I feel like for the older sister
that was just such a beautiful thing to capture in
that recognizing that the best way to honor
someone's Legacy is to to live it yourself
um and the only way that that she could do
that was by being in a position where she
was helpless and had to just accept what yeah I
also like the death choice of converting back into
energy because we're all made of star stuff so
being converted back into Stardust and literally
becoming a star that watches over I think is a
a fantastic some people believe that that's what
happens there's not a lot a lot of definitive laws
of science but the laws of energy are pretty clear
and you cannot be destroyed it can only be moved
and transformed yeah so I love that being the
afterlife thought for it and I I think a lot of
what I loved particularly about this last piece is
there is such a great subtle implementation of
other cultures a lot of African inspiration Kenyan
cultural references that I I saw on there and
don't try to sound smart uh sure uh I could name
countries no I mean I just thought in general it
was it's really interesting and I'm sure like if
you were to dig a little bit deeper like I'm sure
probably even some of like the ritual elements and
things that we saw are probably coming directly
from like very Niche like yeah like historical
family culture storytelling medium like this is
ripe for that sort of deeper dive into something
that honors and respects culture uh and can share
the beauty of it for as long as humankind's been
around like we've seen our ancestors in the
stars and uh yeah there's something beautiful
and Timeless about that um overall this is
a major upgrade from season one of Visions
I feel like they they touched on so many really
like interesting spiritual cornerstones of like
the essence of choice of like grief of feeling
lost and and looking for something different
and not necessarily considering the implications
of that if it means getting out of your current
situation I turned 30 yesterday Greg all those
Concepts really resonate with me from a lower
perspective the cave painting sequence um it
reminded me of one of my favorite sequences in
Rebels uh where they're explaining how tarview's
saber and all that good stuff um and I think it's
just like as a Storyteller that's something that
always kind of gives me goosebumps is that seeing
something animated on a cave wall literally
brings us back to the very first like like
artistic storytelling medium that we had outside
of being in front of a campfire and it's just
amazing to me that in the year 2023 we still find
ways to bring that to life and that it still gives
me goosebumps it's nice to know that me and my
uncle neanderthals uh have something Amen to that
Michael ready for the next one yeah we're gonna
end this uh YouTube video right here thank you
guys so much for being here join us our patreon
thank you for sponsoring these segments uh of
course I'll see you guys in the next video thanks
for being here May the force be with you [Music]